Now, let's go back to
our cache optimizations,
which are about reducing the AMAT.
We have seen that AMAT can be
reduced by reducing the hit time.
And we have seen several
techniques that do this.
The AMAT can also be reduced
by reducing the miss rate.
And we will now look at some
techniques that try to do that.
So, in our work on
reducing the miss rate,
we really need to consider
what are the causes of misses.
So, what can cause misses.
And the causes of misses
are what we call the 3Cs.
You should remember this because very
often, we will refer to the 3Cs.
And you need to know that
the 3Cs are compulsory misses,
capacity misses and conflict misses.
A compulsory miss is a miss that
occurs when a block is accessed for
the first time.
It's called compulsory because
you have to have this miss.
So even if we have an infinite cache
that starts out empty, we would still
have the compulsory misses, but we would
not have any of the other two kinds.
So a compulsory miss is a miss you
have to have simply because for
the first time you have to
bring a block into the cache.
Capacity misses are misses that we
have on blocks that were in the cache,
but were evicted because we didn't
have enough room in the cache
because the cache is of a finite size.
So these are misses that we would not
have in an infinite cache but capacity
misses would be misses even in a
fully-associative cache of a given size.
So for example,
if we have an eight kilobyte cache
that is let's say direct map,
we have a capacity miss.
If that block would not
be found in the cache,
even if it was fully-associative
eight kilobyte cache.
And finally, conflict misses occur
because of conflicts within a set.
So the block was evicted not because the
cache didn't have enough space in it,
but because it had
limited associativity.
So a conflict miss is a miss
that would not be a miss
if the cache was fully associative and
of the same size.
So now some of
the obvious techniques for
using the miss rate will
target some of these.
So for example,
a larger cache would help us reduce
a number of capacity misses.
A larger associativity would help
us reduce the conflict misses.
A better replacement policy would
also help us with conflict misses.
But all of those techniques
also affect the hit time.
So now let's look at some techniques
that are trying to reduce the miss rate
without necessarily increasing
the hit time in return.